inside here comes trouble Anthony and
that's over
Bogdanovic there certainly would have
been in technical in Australian rules
Ramos drill here comes Ingles he's hit
two threes kid about father-son that's
four of four and since they put him in
the record has been good back better
than when Conley was playing and these
feet away put in by team this is first
quarter so far here for Quin Snyder in
Utah their gums will lose one or two
they'll put up a three on the fly moody
a late that's right down the hatch by
Jamie and Lillard he could be the
primary scorer with this second unit
where Mitchell can help be the
facilitator as the BC air gets one to go
that's two of three for Clarkson this is
a 1/2 screen and roll sweet check that
he gets to do it three-point shot to
fall there comes Mitchell Iceland
[Applause]
he played on that North Carolina NCAA
championship team and when it's gotten
back in freshly with hitting some shots
in close ten points in the paint this
second quarter here comes Lillard O'Neal
move it off good fake by Jane got the
two boys O'Neal in the corner the end
out there for the Blazers scientist out
there who drops a hammer with a nice
feed from tanada Mitchell all with the
clock at 359
[Music]
Bazemore as well
I mean Engels has just been on fire here
milord three that's good after going all
of 10 top of the truck he brought him
into the series little picked up by
Whiteside try to get something early in
transition here do takes it right to the
rack and here is Lillard in transition
on that previous possession getting all
the way to the hole but the reason why
you try shooting 56% Jonathan Mitchell
the smoothness here of Mitchell behind
his back kind of sins McCullough off
balance here the step-back routines
right now in the playoff mix number
eight against number six blazers number
eight Utah number six three o'clock at
7:00 the three rebound by Lillard out
there at McCullum they got Carmelo
Anthony Bazemore here's McCullum three
good something he did not do in the
first half I just said eight altogether
Gwyn Snyder's trying to melt into one
tonight Donovan Mitchell one four five
five seven and nine of the last 14 games
there is Mitchell outside Ingles three
[Applause]
11:01 here to start this third quarter
for the Jazz ingles it was vacuumed in
bangles and they come the other way
starters on the floor I'm the wing oh
nice Mitchell my goodness so the pieces
on paper are great is just now finding
that chemistry with a die even a tribe
in a lamp and they'll put it up in
brooms a drought of about 420 for the
Blazers pitch strength and concentration
here by Whiteside there's the push down
low these games go to the NBA right
there by Lillard
[Music]
good friend Roy Williams a North
Carolina broaching to the play here on
the 3rd liminal good step back to let's
go
a toe run alone here by Damien Lilith
restart ur Zack Collins oh yeah did the
to step inside oh man what a beautiful
move there by Mitch ring Snider dropped
a lot and he tried to work on being
effective pretty play by talented
Mitchell is efficiency with his
decision-making well Mitchell now
starting to own the paint here
notice the defensive you jog which they
hang their hat on first they're only in
seventh in points allowed print that is
a three they can wind down the third
Mitchell driving on Miller
than the troll for the Portland
Trailblazers for the five starters for
the Jazz and double figures including
down to the Mitchell right here is
absolutely owning it this is over
Ingalls for three rebound by Mitchell
quick outline angles into silence go to
his only hit the other hand against the
young player
Ingalls picks up his first foul look at
this lead path look how long look at
this nice Euro take my time is Mitchell
we have 13 in the third quarter for just
two in the fourth Simon's the 23 points
and that to the Blazers have done they
have stuck to it shot in the difficult
one put in by tame you're welcome it's
agree of difficulty at 30 footer
O'Neil knocked away by salmon to the
pass got off the Mitchell tribes on
Salmons from the - but look at Mitchell
he has absolutely been dominating the
[Applause]
pitch Simon's there little bit of in DCU
two-point game 15.1 what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content